entre aplausos el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin inauguró el foro
económico oriental celebrado en el
puerto ruso de vladivostok con un
discurso marcadamente nacionalista en
medio de la creciente presión de
occidente que enfrenta a rusia desde el
inicio de la invasión australia
aunque algunos quieren aislar a rusia
como siempre hemos dicho es imposible
sólo hay que mirar el mapa de tamboril
nievas mosna uno de los principales
puntos del foro la energía tras el corte
de suministro de gas del nostre 1 el 31
de agosto por un supuesto mantenimiento
la unión europea ha sostenido que rusia
utiliza la energía como arma y chantaje
algo que el dirigente ruso ha negado
aunque ha advertido que si se llegara a
imponer un límite sobre el precio del
gas rusia detendrá el suministro
prisión además están las obligaciones
contractuales un contrato de suministro
alguien va a tomar algún tipo de
decisiones políticas que vayan en contra
de los contratos simplemente no
cumpliremos con los contratos
suministraremos nada si va en contra de
nuestros intereses económicos en este
caso no suministraremos gas petróleo
carbón o combustible para calefacción
nada admite que tom austin ante los
crecientes temores por la tensión en la
central nuclear de zamorilla rusia culpó
a ucrania de crear amenazas para la
seguridad nuclear con sus ataques ya que
supuestamente moscú no ha desplegado
armamento en la central y he visto que
el informe del oiea dice que hay que
retirar el equipo militar de la zona de
la central pero no hay equipo militar en
la estación y otra en haití que lejos de
mostrar arrepentimiento útil la mantiene
que la guerra en ucrania ha beneficiado
a rusia ya su soberanía para poder
desarrollarse y hacer frente al orden
occidental en el mundo